[Music]
hey folks welcome back to the dark horse
podcast the podcast we know that god
loves because nothing ever goes
wrong how was that is the uh is the
sound fixed do we know do we know we
don't know how about my sound anyone
do either of us sound like barry white
that's
the question
on the table i guess we will find out
soon enough for the vast majority of
people who are listening to this who
weren't here for our first start 10 15
20 minutes ago i don't know was it hours
by now um apparently the sound was off
enough that some reports came in uh that
i sounded just a bit deeper than usual
but brett actually sounded like barry
white which was um people were wondering
if this was maybe intentional but now
right it was an opportunity to reinvent
myself had i seen it coming but uh
caught off guard as i was it did not uh
did not work out that way did not work
out that way here we are episode number
105 episode number one that was actually
going to be my guess
was it yes i'm not sure why i have to
guess you would think i have as much
information on this topic as anyone but
uh that was going to be my guess it's
going to be your guess
well we have um we have as usual a lot
of things to talk to you guys about
today we also have
a number of episodes of dark horse that
brett has done with outside guests that
are going to start being released soon
so look forward to those as well it's
not just going to be our live streams
um hopefully every saturday for um the
the foreseeable future but we're getting
back into some of these um hosted
episodes with outside guests yeah i
wouldn't say it's something for everyone
but there's definitely something for for
some people there it will be
uh quite jaw-dropping in in many regards
yeah these episodes are we have
something for some of you some of the
time
right exactly it's a little it's the
opposite of the internet but
even though ironically here we are on
the internet
all right we're going to be talking a
bit uh about catch-22 uh we've i've read
to you before from catch-22 i forgot i
didn't take a note of what episode that
was in but we've got a different excerpt
today to talk about
um it seems apropos a number of people
feel like they're in catch actual catch
22s right now so this is not actually
about
the
the situation that heller named in the
title of the book but uh something from
the book
um some
you know i'm not going to tell us i'm
not going to talk about where all we're
going we're just going a bunch of places
we're going to finish up by talking a
little bit about places they want to
know they got to stick around place and
the moment we're in and thanksgiving and
being grateful and and all of that all
right yeah
so um
we at the moment we are on youtube and
odyssey uh it's not working very well in
either place unfortunately but that's
where we are at the moment chat is live
on odyssey you can ask questions for the
q a at darkhorsesubmissions.com
right now at my patreon the 48 hour
period during which you can ask
questions that we will then consider for
our live q a at the end of every month
is on so
you can join there now and we
we have a new product uh in our store
for the first time we're going to have
at least four more in the next couple of
weeks
knowing that some number of people are
going to be thinking about
thinking about purchasing things for
their family and friends in the upcoming
weeks it's a great way to support us and
to do some of your holiday shopping
that's right um we have
we have been working with just an
amazing artist who uh next week actually
will be able to link to some of his
other work
but zach if you would show
my screen for the moment oops
this is uh
the newest art welcome to complex
systems for those who are only listening
it's got
a crocodilian with a bird plural in its
mouth uh doing sort of the tooth
cleaning that uh
that
that crocodilians have in association
with with birds under some circumstances
and we're going to this is going to be
the first in a series of welcome to
complex systems we you know this is a
phrase we use a lot and there are just
complex systems everywhere you look the
other
few things that we have coming out in
the next couple weeks aren't welcome to
complex systems we'll have more of those
too so that is available in hoodie and
t-shirts i think on a tote bag and the
rendering here is not perfect but the
art is gorgeous it's really really
beautiful yes if demand is high enough
we will
endeavor to get this on a radio
telescope really yes
so for purchase by individuals uh for
viewing at a great distance i see yeah
that's terrific
okay
it's gonna be one of those days i guess
i think i think yeah yeah i think it is
um
okay why don't we just go right into
that we got three ads this week um and
let's let's do it
all right
we are grateful to our sponsors as we
have mentioned before we choose our
sponsors carefully we do not uh read ads
for anyone any products that we actually
do not support so we are
truthfully and honestly
thrilled to have these guys as our
sponsors and i'm very pleased with these
products the first ad for this week is
relief band a product that can help with
nausea
first though a little bit about nausea
under ancient circumstances and some
modern ones nausea was generally a
useful signal that something is off
you'd eaten something that you shouldn't
have or were near something emanating a
bad smell itself a signal that you
should not get near that thing
in modernity we still need to track our
bodily sensitivities we should not
always choose to simply erase discomfort
like nausea whenever we feel it that
said some of modernity creates nausea
that does no good at all travel sickness
for instance can be agonizing and relief
would be lovely
inter relief band
relief band is an anti-nausea wrist band
that has been clinically proven to
relieve and prevent nausea associated
with motion sickness anxiety migraines
chemotherapy and more relief band is 100
drug free and can be used for as long as
you need it developed over 20 years ago
it is the only over-the-counter wearable
device that has been used in hospitals
and oncology clinics to treat nausea and
vomiting and relief band just released
its newest model relief band sport the
sport is waterproof features
interchangeable bands and has extended
battery life we asked a friend to try it
out here is her testimonial because we
we are lucky enough neither of us to
particularly experience nausea so we
were unwilling to have this as a sponsor
unless we knew someone who we trust very
well who could attest to its awesomeness
and she does she says i used to have
nausea on a near daily basis for both
anxiety and the need to take regular
medication relief band released my
nausea in less than three minutes
without the side effects i was
experiencing from anti-nausea medication
it has entirely changed my life for the
better
so if you've got nausea from anxiety or
car or seasickness or something else you
cannot otherwise disable consider relief
band
as the holiday season quickly approaches
there's never been a better time to give
the gift of relief and make sure your
loved ones are nausea free right now
relief band is running their biggest
sale of the year head to relief band
you'll receive 25 off all orders you
don't even need a promo code don't miss
out on this deal that's
r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d
dot com and receive 25 off all orders to
november 28th
all right you know i'm beginning to miss
travel so much i might even miss travel
sickness at some point oh man yes yes i
know yes all right our second sponsor is
public goods public goods can simplify
your life as a one-stop shop for
everyday essentials their ingredients
are carefully sourced high quality and
affordable public goods has ramen and
mustard deodorant and dental floss
shampoo coffee a french press to make it
in
they've got grain free granola which i
think should be called grain free green
frenola
and curry paste flatware and towels
there's so much at public goods to make
a meal and the materials to serve it on
we've tried several of their products
and have not been disappointed public
goods products have a great design too
the aesthetic is simple and clean this
is such an important point
this stuff looks good
and it does not impose
there are no garish colors
we don't want the products that we use
to draw attention themselves so public
goods is a great fit public goods cares
about health and sustainability their
products are largely free of harmful
ingredients and additives and the
ingredients are ethically sourced they
also plant one tree for every order
placed finally their subscription
service is efficient and simple and easy
to use public goods members can buy all
of their premium essentials in one place
it really is an everything store for
dark horse listeners we have the
following offer receive 15 off your
first public goods order with no minimum
they are so confident that you will
absolutely
love their products and come back again
and again that they are giving you
fifteen dollars to spend on your first
purchase go to publicgoods.com
darkhorse use the code darkhorse at
checkout
that is public goods p u b l i c g o o d
s dot com forward slash darkhorse to
receive 15 off your first order all
right and finally this episode is
sponsored by four sigmatic
and i am not talking zachary
i'm sorry finally this episode is
sponsored by four sigmatic a wellness
company known for its delicious mushroom
coffee as well as protein powders that
contain mushrooms i know that sounds
weird a little bit off-putting i was
skeptical but i've been drinking their
mushroom coffee lately most mornings and
it's very very good four sigmatics
mushroom coffee contains organic fair
trade single origin arabica coffee with
both lions man and chaga mushrooms
four sigmatics ground mushroom coffee
with lion's mane adds a little something
some christmas some focus i sense it's
delicious just like your favorite coffee
dark and nutty
all four sigmatic products are organic
vegan and gluten free and every batch is
third party lab tested to ensure its
purity and safety
four sigmatic has a 100 money back
guarantee love every sip or get your
money back
we have an exclusive offer with four
sigmatic on their best-selling mushroom
coffee for dark horse listeners get up
to 40 off that's 4-0 plus free shipping
on mushroom coffee bundles to claim this
deal go to 4sigmatic.com
darkhorse i should say forward slash and
i never do i think people know they know
they know yeah
um that's
for sigmatic f-o-u-r-s-i-g-m-a-t-i-c
dot com
[Music]
slash darkhorse and fuel your
productivity and creativity with some
delicious mushroom coffee all right
all right again we are very grateful for
our sponsors
and um excuse me they in an era of um
demonetization and shadow banning and a
great epidemic of cowardice and the
great epidemic of cowardice
um are uh are
helping us helping us do this they are
demonstrating courage which is it's
tough if you're in business it's tough
yeah so we we are really grateful to
them and supporting them
is a way to get your needs taken care of
as you support us and support businesses
that are demonstrating courage that is
all too rare indeed and we've been
thinking
a lot about courage this week and about
compliance
and about
um
really at some level this this just
little excerpt from catch 22 which you
would remember it and i and i found in
in our book here
um
was prompted by our talking about how so
many of the renditions
of the
the resistors
the um those those who do not comply
those who uh say no i'm not going along
the the life that is portrayed of them
tends to be one of
um
one of darkness and um paucity and one
of austerity austerity and sort of you
know the image that comes right it's
always it's sort of like a grayscale
you know
liquid of unknown provenance dripping
from ducts onto you you can't ever quite
get warm or dry there are very few
comforts it's a dreary dark choice but
you know if you're that kind of person
then you go
and we wanted to talk
about
the other way to view this right and in
fact the reality so there's of course a
great deal of effort invested in
spooking people into imagining that if
they say what they see then terrible
things will befall them and you know
that keeps a lot of people in line and
it's not that you don't want rats
crawling over your toes while you sleep
do you
i don't no i don't think so um
but i mean that's the sort of thing that
that's that's the imagery right like
okay
you step out of line and pretty before
you know it that's the kind of life
you're going to be having right and
indeed you know uh
in the current environment i should
point out that when you say resistors
there is this hashtag resistance thing
that i don't want any partners i don't
even know that um well it's a you know
it's a throwback to the um the election
in fact the 2016 election but the idea
is it's a branded kind of resistance
rather than people who are actually
resisting
the orthodoxy in fact it's become a kind
of orthodoxy but nonetheless there is
this interesting phenomenon
where if you actually do
first principles thinking you call it
like you see it and you do so publicly
things do happen
right and not all of them are good to be
sure and we have um
lost uh quite a number of friends in uh
in recent times uh over calling it like
we see it uh
with respect to issues related to the
pandemic guess what else though
the other thing though what they don't
manage to convey is that this causes a
kind of upgrade in your social life
because the people who uh
you know publicly chastise you in such
circumstances are actually not high
quality they may seem like it under
normal circumstances but
when the chips are down they won't be
there and that's actually uh a very uh
important thing to know we learned this
at evergreen too right but let's just be
very clear and i know you know
the the viewers who are longtime viewers
who are coming here because they find
something of value uh will not have made
this error
but i could hear what you just said as
suggesting that if you get critiqued you
know that person isn't no no no no is it
doing you a solid and isn't worth having
a right no no a great friend will
critique you they will do it carefully
but there is uh you know there is this
public distancing thing that uh is of a
very different sort and we saw this at
evergreen and of course the first time
we learned this lesson when this
happened at evergreen you know there
were lots of people who we had thought
were our friends who turned out not to
be up to the challenge
but a great many people emerged and the
point was the trade was very positive
right the upgrade and the quality of
people that surrounded us was amazing
now that what we would say at the time
in fact was that there were surprises in
both directions and we've been we've
begun asking some of the some of our new
friends some of the people who we are
coming into contact with okay when you
when you spoke up when you became public
on whatever topic it is
uh that you are now persona non grata in
your former social circles did you find
you know what did you find out we try
not to lead the witness you know we try
not to tell people what it is that we
already think we know and what what
people
say over and over again is it it is a
reaffirmation of what we ourselves found
which is that there are surprises in
both directions meaning that some of the
people who we thought
would be
loyal as friends even if they didn't
agree with the conclusions um
were not you know were cowardly word
disloyal did not act as friends and some
people with whom we actually didn't know
that we had any affinity or affiliation
at all stood up and acted courageously
and boldly because they too could not
bear uh to observe uh an injustice or
you know um
you know authoritarianism flying under
the banner of anti-racism or science or
whatever it is right so
i guess what i would say is you know you
could simply count heads right and
frankly i don't know what the
net is our social circle grew a lot
after uh evergreen that's not
necessarily what's taken place uh in
modern times but the point is if you do
so waiting for quality then what you
find is that actually you discover
incredibly um
interesting dynamic
people who are excellent at careful
thought right and so anyway there is
this kind of upgrade phenomenon that is
not famous people do not know that you
know that this is part of the equation
and so there is a question when we do
hear from people
and i think this is justified uh you
know okay but but you guys us we're
findable and indeed so many people reach
out to us that we don't we we aren't
able to respond to most people who do
and so i'm sure you know we miss lots of
people who are amazing who reach out to
us who we just never follow through with
because because we don't have too many
yeah um we don't have the the time for
it um we don't have that you know time
is finite um but for tho for those of
you who don't have a way like how how do
people find one another and i guess
that's you know what we're trying to say
is
being courageous is
not inherently going to
bring you a life in which rats are
running over your toes in your sleep um
but how is it that people find the
community of other people like them who
are
who are not seeing the world the way
they're being told to see it
well
i think
what what my impression after evergreen
was i wish you know
if there were to be you know a minute of
supernatural stuff right and you could
pick what the supernatural thing was the
ability to know
who actually had the characteristics
that would um
render them strong in adverse
circumstances and who
seemed like they might be that person
but was destined to disappoint this is
the most important piece of information
you could have right you do not want to
discover once you're in the foxhole that
the person who talked a good game
actually has no courage and will sell
you out right
you don't want that you want to know
ahead of time who really has the depth
of character so that what you encounter
on the surface
is actually indicative of what's below
and you don't know that until a severe
challenge and so
um in essence there is no substitute
for
the high pressure test of the system so
i i guess my point is i believe that
anybody who stands up will discover this
they will find out that many around them
who they think are you know and who are
uh more than decent under normal
circumstances will fail the test under
dire circumstances
well so two things i hope i remember
both of them here um
we have found
you know when we are anonymous in the
world as we're moving about and
increasingly that's not necessarily the
case and frankly i i
mourn the loss of anonymity because for
me as an animal behaviorist a lot of
what i learn about people is by going
out into the world and not just
observing but interacting with them as
just you know a human being who doesn't
already have stated opinions in the
world
um and you know i do we we get
recognized and approached and it's it's
lovely we've yet to be approached by
anyone for with whom it wasn't lovely
but i always feel a sort of sense of
like oh i you know that means that i
can't do that i can't be learning in the
way that i would be learning from here
because i don't know to what degree this
is um
this is a show right
um
but when we have both you and i do this
in somewhat different ways and largely
in
overlapping but somewhat non-overlapping
like retail venues
ask people just show any little
indicator of not being totally on board
with whatever the dominant paradigm is
right now and this you know last in
summer of 2020 here in portland it was
largely about the responses to
uh the protesters that became rioters
every night and it was about the you
know shutting down police and it was uh
it was about black lives matter and
increasingly it's about
you know lockdowns and outdoor masks
and and vaccine mandates and it is
amazing how many people seem not only
willing but eager to take the smallest
hint that maybe you were not an
automaton that maybe you haven't
swallowed the dominant thing hook line
and sinker and will then just talk we'll
talk in sometimes a little bit but
sometimes it seems like they're going
for hours about what it is they're
actually seeing what they think it means
and how
how bad
the public policy and the uniform public
response seems to be
yeah actually um
i
i'm sure i'm sure that this has been
understood
by those who have analyzed
authoritarianism but one of the
hallmarks has to be when you you know
coerce a population into compliance
the pressure on individuals
is immense and the
desire for those individuals to find
somebody that they can actually be safe
in talking about what they don't like
about it in other words there's a danger
in confessing yeah actually i'm not on
board with this
right even if i'm complying it's not
because i think this is a good idea
but people cannot people will not in
general be public about this because the
hazard of saying the wrong thing to the
wrong person is too great um so if you
you know put out a little bit of bat
signal
yes i do have a cat who's crawling in my
lap here if you put out a little bit of
a bat signal
right and i mean in fact this is this is
where we are i would say
on masks
right
the mask thing has clearly become about
compliance and i will say for the
thousandth time we were
extremely early on the idea of masks and
um the failure of the evidence it seemed
obvious it seemed we were compelled
that it seemed obvious and that the u.s
surgeon general and the who you know
fouchy and everyone else is like don't
wear masks that would be foolish and
then they came out with like no actually
that was to preserve the ppe for the
healthcare workers
that that seemed obvious to us i think i
think we were wrong right i think we i
think we were wrong i think there is a
small amount of good it's not enough to
justify
mandates it requires
a certain kinds of masks b it requires
that they be worn in very particular
ways and the point is it's just not
justified but it's been a marvelous
policy from the point of view of
discovering who will they agree to this
right who will go along with uh with
mandates that make no sense and it's
been just you know really picture
perfect with respect to taking the
message be frightened and transporting
it everywhere it rides around with every
citizen who has to put on a mask or walk
around with it er we get these reminders
constantly you know there's a pandemic
these people are a danger to you right
and now the thing is the unmasked the
unvaccinated the uns
are dirty and dangerous yeah and perhaps
evil
right now
you and i
um are compliant mask-wise we don't fail
we live in a state and a
city a state and a coast um that is
largely masked right so we put them on
we are not flaunting inside inside
retail establishments except when we're
eating well no no no hold on we are
compliant with
the requirement to wear a mask the harm
while
there is small enough that we are not
going to
ignore the rule
however
there is no rule that says you have to
play along with the idea that this makes
sense right and so
when one sits down at the table and
takes off their mask in a restaurant as
if they're you know as if this is like
smoke that if you get below it you can
you can breathe again um you know one is
perfectly free to evidence yes i'm
complying but i think this is nonsense
um well i think it's actually it's an oh
sorry um it was it's i was in a booth in
a restaurant in austin actually with
uh with a friend and he said wow this is
like the one square mile in all of texas
where masks are required and if he
actually had not come with one and i was
able i was like oh god i have so many
here take one of mine
and we sat down and because we're in a
booth he said oh it's it's not about the
smoke it's actually there's the
invisible force field that comes across
the booth and as long as everyone else
stays outside of our force field we have
no chance of spreading the thing that we
don't have right the thing that you
don't have right and you know you the
the paradoxes are so many you know when
you have
you know the the waiter comes over
wearing a mask right and you're sitting
there not masked and actually my sense
is to the extent that this does any good
at all we're more or less morally
obligated to put them on at that moment
to protect this person right it is only
because i don't think this is a very
effective remedy that i don't think this
is a glaring error because it's you know
i mean that's what i was doing until i
started to see all of this um
all of this work suggesting that they're
not actually particularly effective yeah
but anyway yes um
a little bat signal that suggests uh i
don't think this policy is all that well
thought out is liable to put you in
contact with others who have those
doubts and are likely feeling very
isolated about them themselves yeah and
really there's a
there's a smugness that some people are
willing and eager to
to convey
uh and then
it's not there's everyone else
but it that is one of the ways that is
one of the dichotomies that i am seeing
now there's the smug
who
largely you know are actually
functionally enumerate i think and um
and get your nose out of my water um she
is not talking to me for those of you
listening to the podcast he's talking to
the cat
um
and you know who say things like follow
the science but don't actually you know
wouldn't recognize a hypothesis if it
smacked them in the nose
and then there's sort of everyone else
and yes there are degrees to which um
the everyone else have conclusions that
they're certain of or not certain of or
have investigated them as much as
possible for first principles
but there is a degree of uncertainty
the you know the smug are inherently
certain and if you're certain right now
that the thing that got handed you by
the cdc or msnbc or anyone is simply
true on account if it got handed to you
then you're not doing your thinking for
yourself and frankly your smugness is
should evaporate right away because it's
based on nothing good yes and so i think
we're heading towards the ultimate point
here which is
um many people are
living
under different multiple layers of fear
one of those fears is about what happens
if you acknowledge your doubts and
indeed you are being encouraged to
believe that what happens if you
acknowledge your doubts is going to be
dire and
we're not going to tell you that there
are not serious consequences there are
and we've experienced them
however there is another side
to the puzzle which is how you will feel
when your doubts are no longer a secret
that you are afraid is going to be
discovered and that's what the quote
from
from catch 22 reveals yeah okay let's do
it so this is from this is from to the
middle of the book uh i forgot the
chapter
it's
nope it's not milo the mayor
it's natalie's old man
not reading the whole chapter just about
a page here
so this is um
this is a young this is uh set it up 19
yeah go for it uh you wouldn't set up
the whole book
oh sure no no i thought that's what you
were about to do no i was just going to
set up the scene okay so the scene
involves uh one of these young pilots
pilots had a very very dangerous role uh
in in world war ii um a lot of them did
not come back most of them did not come
back so it was a very terrifying thing
and this exchange takes place um hold on
so it's a piece of fiction but heller
himself was was he a bombardier
uh he was he was i think he was in
planes but i don't remember um in any
case
the exchange takes place uh obviously if
you're a pilot you're
unless you're based on an aircraft
carrier based on land but this is the
equivalent of shore leave where they've
gone into into italy
and they're at the [ __ ] house and the
old man is the proprietor of the [ __ ]
house and i believe he's talking to
nately is that right
and nately is a young gun at a 20-ish
year old
guy who is basically pontificating on
his understanding of how the world works
and this
extremely old uh man the proprietor of a
whorehouse who knows a whole lot about
how the world actually works
responds and says all kinds of
interesting sometimes hilarious things
and anyway this this exchange takes
place
yeah i mean it goes on for a long time
i'm just going to read the short little
bit here
the old man says about someone who um
had risked his life you see imagine a
man his age risking what little life he
has left for something so absurd as a
country
nately was instantly up in arms again
there was nothing so absurd about
risking your life for your country he
declared
isn't there ask the old man what is a
country a country is a piece of land
surrounding all sides by boundaries
usually unnatural englishmen are dying
for england americans are dying for
america germans are dying for germany
russians are dying for russia there are
now 50 or 60 countries fighting in this
war surely so many countries can't all
be worth dying for
anything worth living for said nately is
worth dying for
and anything worth dying for answered
the sacrilegious old man is certainly
worth living for you know you're such a
pure and naive young man that i almost
feel sorry for you how old are you 25 26
19 said natalie i'll be 20 in january
if you live
the old man shook his head wearing for a
moment the same touchy meditating frown
of the fretful and disapproving old
woman
they're going to kill you if you don't
watch out and i can see now that you're
not gonna watch out why don't you use
some sense and try to be more like me
you might live to be 107 too
because it's better to die on one's feet
than to live on one's knee neatly
retorted with triumphant and lofty
conviction i guess you've heard that
saying before
yes i certainly have used the
treacherous old man smiling again but
i'm afraid that you have it backwards it
is better to live on one's feet than die
on one's knees
that is the way the saying goes
it is better to live on one's feet than
dying one's knees that uh that line has
given me chills for
i don't know
three decades three and a half decades
since i first read it there's something
about it the idea that we have this
thing encoded in our minds about you
know it's uh better to die on one's feet
than live on one's knees and that in
fact we don't even notice this other
possibility right it's ruled out by the
way that the initial thing is phrased
and the point is
um
well i guess it's another version of
plato's cave in some sense right the
idea that there's this other reality
that you can't quite see but if you knew
what it was you would value things very
very differently
well it raises questions of whether or
not where you are at the moment like
are you on your feet or are you on your
knees like that that is the sort of
plato's cave what world is it what
looking glass have you or have you not
gone through
you know what what is your situation
right now how free are you
yeah how free how free are you and
you know it's funny i i have never
thought of it this way
before i've long loved catch-22 there's
so much in it you know it's so
brilliantly done where you know the word
play is
wonderful and the comedy is
utterly hilarious and
plenty dark and all of that but
um but i've never thought of it as a
dystopian novel before
but i'm beginning to wonder you know i'm
i'm hearing discussions about
um about dystopia and about what we are
facing and i think everybody who gets it
realizes
it's not orwellian it's not kafka right
it's it's not huxley
it's pieces of these things it's a
hybrid between these things but the
hybridization goes beyond those classics
right it definitely extends to brazil
right there's an element about this that
is
the movie that is that is brazil that's
the yeah brazil the movie but also catch
22 right
and i think the point is how many of
these great um
uh texts or whatever they are
does one need to have a piece that
covers all of the things that we're uh
encountering
and then you know if you know i i do
long for a circumstance in which we have
all had enough shared grounding that we
can have the conversation right that you
can say kafka trap and it doesn't you
know leave a third of the audience
wondering what the heck you're talking
about
well that of course is some of what um
you know stereotypically conservatives
bemoan about the loss of
a classic great books curriculum for
instance right that there was
that there was a shared cultural set of
knowledge
that you could know if you were
interacting with people from the same
rough sort of cultural class
they they would know and frankly uh this
is this was also true about
uh
what like from our childhood it's like
must-see tv
right you know thursday night on nbc
uh everyone watched the same stuff such
that if you had the kind of job that had
a water cooler the next day you all had
seen you know the huxtables on the cosby
show the night before and you all could
talk about these you know fictional
people um who were who were imagined to
be living lives but you know they were
as if friends so you know your work your
workplace brought together all these
people who live separate lives but they
had this shared thing that was that was
brought into their in their homes every
every thursday
and
of course you know both the loss of both
um
classic traditional curricula
and of
uh
television or other media that actually
comes in at a particular moment as
opposed to when it is that you have the
time
uh you know both of which have reason
the changes the reasons for the changes
are not entirely bad right and the
changes themselves are of course not
entirely bad but there are trade-offs
and we have we there is very little now
that synchronizes us
well um except for this forced consensus
that we are told we are all synchronized
we all know that
you know the un's are dirty right when
we are synchronized by something that is
that is the opposite of education right
it is it is mis-education or something
like that i have to say that when
whenever you say curricula i think of an
academic vampire i just can't help but
curriculum yeah um female presumably
no but that's great well i guess dracula
is not yeah no
maybe he is now but um
[Music]
perhaps yes perhaps um who's to say
dracula only dracula yes um lived
experience being primal right not primal
uh
unlived experiences
oh boy all right good uh but too late
for halloween yeah we're there right in
time for thanksgiving halloween is the
unlived experience yes um
all right so the point i wanted to make
i have i have also made this this point
about um
you know the uh the shared
the shared um
god doesn't play dice but fairfax does
he sure does um
he's now about to eat a rubber band that
could end badly um what has gotten into
all of us this week really so i think
the problem is the conservatives don't
have it right right the great books
curriculum is not the is not the
curriculum for modern times neither is
the um
uh the
liberal arts uh grab bag
right and the point is
so i don't know what you mean by the
liberal liberal arts grab bag i mean
as i've said a number of times i think
liberal arts
is
the central concept of liberal arts
which is basically a an education that
is not about training you
uh is correct but that liberal arts
itself learning how to think and
helping reveal to you
what you can and cannot do and it is
about upgrading the mind
and
the
problem with it is that upgrading the
mind you know
gets into a question of okay what is
what do we regard as an upgrade right
and the point is
i would say any
uh education that does not give you
basic competence in scientific thinking
and math is as a failure right if a
liberal arts education can include an
education that doesn't have that then
it's a failed concept to me
but anyway the point is what we need is
some sort of
great book some hybrid between a liberal
arts style thinking which is too
flexible because it doesn't give us a
shared set of
concepts that allows us all to interact
with the same baseline
right
and then the great books thing the
problem with that one is that it is too
grounded at the moment that you declare
these books great and the point is the
amount of
the amount that we know about the
universe is changing and so what are the
chances that that group of books that
one most ought to prioritize is static
what it really is is it has to be
a dynamic frame that still prioritizes
the sharedness and you know your point
about
must-see tv
um i i agree and the point is musty tv i
don't think it was
except it wasn't important it wasn't
good
but but much more important
than
good is
shared in some sense and i've said this
about books themselves that in some
sense the the
the important thing is that people have
have been run through the same
experience so that they have a basis for
interacting over it rather than
everybody having an a la carte
experience which can be a higher quality
experience because it's tailored to you
but it means that you know the us part
doesn't work as well so
yeah there is something to having at
least you know you know i've made the
point that uh
musically the era of lps and a small
number of radio stations which dispensed
music into your car in your house
was not that wasn't a natural moment
right it seems more natural than our
current moment but no it's just the
moment we were born into and the point
was though that you know there's nothing
natural about having every radio station
playing stairway to heaven during a
particular month because it's the latest
craze but it did give you know it meant
that if you met somebody from a
different high school they were also
having a piece of the same experience it
also allows you to place your memories
in time later right like you know we
stairway to heaven was big when we were
tiny kids so you know we weren't we
weren't around for that moment but
um
you they're
in in the 80s when we were in high
school
um
there
there was a soundtrack to that era
uh that frankly a lot of retail stores
are now playing you know like we are the
target audience for a lot of a lot of
retail stores
and it pulls you right back right it
builds you right back and that is to
some degree true now of course like
there's music coming out right now that
will only ever have come out in 2021
because that's just what history and the
you know the truth of time and reality
is um but there's so much of it and it's
so
sort of desynchronized
uh that there won't be there can't be a
like oh you know remember remember the
month
that ever all the radio stations were
suddenly playing x and also you know the
earthquake happened in y and that
happens to be the month that i broke up
my first boyfriend or oh really because
that was the month that i first tried
sushi you know whatever it is like you
you can come together over like okay
there are these universals
and they're not just
an earthquake in why they're also things
that actually tug at the deepest
emotional truth which is often music
right
and so we we can synchronize with those
things even with people who we didn't
know at the time because they were
experiencing the same thing the same
emotional thing the same musical thing
at the time
and that that is one of the
desynchronizations and therefore i think
the decoherences
of modernity yes with with globalization
of media and social media
surpassing most um most other kinds well
we are seeing two things at once we are
seeing the market deliver because
markets feed individuals because it is
individuals usually who do the spending
right it is feeding us something that
tickles our particular fancy which is
separating us it's it's decohering us at
the same time it's dispensing
mind-numbing narratives where there is
nothing but questions to be asked
there's no question asked and the a
narrative is dispensed as if it was
obviously true and anybody who departs
from this has lost their freaking mind
right so it's the worst of both worlds
right we don't
know each other well and yet we all
believe the same [ __ ]
yeah we're so we you walk around um
you walk around among strangers at the
moment as we still have the opportunity
to do because we live in a city
and uh and when something crazy
happens near you
what should have been able to happen and
what has been true in the past is
you can make eye contact with strangers
and be like just check in whether or not
there are words exchanged like you're
seeing that you both are seeing the
crazy thing that's happening
we know so little about one another now
and we trust each other so little that
it frankly makes the crazy stuff uh it
facilitates the crazy stuff because
there's no checking in even between
strangers and you know in some in some
cases even the attempt to make you know
friendly eye contact is taken as an an
affront and i will say i want to i'm
going to end today by talking a little
bit about
just my experience walking around the
sun this morning and it it i
realized two-thirds of the way into my
walk why it felt so different like a it
was sunny blue skies in november the
pacific northwest which is pretty rare
um but everyone was smiling
everyone i saw smiled at me and i like i
tend to smile at people when i when i
see them out there and from long
long experience actually in
developing world countries that my my
experience is that especially if my
language isn't quite up to it that this
is just sort of an openness like hey i'm
you know i'm going to try here but i
don't know i'm not sure i'm going to be
able to communicate i need to
communicate so i tried to not smile
first at people which is which is hard
for me in that sort of situation today
and
everyone was smiling it wasn't i wasn't
prompting it no one was wearing a met
weird outside no one's wearing a mask
everyone was just out there in the sun
it wasn't warm but you know on a sunny
beautiful day by the river
happy to be out there yeah and
how unusual and how sad that that is
unusual now
unusual and they're all of these
you know
you've known me as long as anyone and
almost you know almost um you know that
i have
freely interacted with anybody who would
interact back
since i was a kid you know i was a
little shy as a kid but
um as i was interacting with anybody i
would interact with just about anybody
and you know
the degree to which
cool interesting conversations
uh sprung up out of nowhere was was
amazing something i learned from my
grandfather
who behaved the same way
and
that has been lost in large measure
because there's this question
you know as we've talked about on the
podcast before
if i'm interacting with a woman there's
an immediate question as to whether i'm
a creep right if i'm interacting with
somebody of a different race there's an
immediate question about
you know
am i
one of these uh
you know
largely imagined uh racists right am i
serving my own interests trying to feel
better about my privilege by talking to
somebody of a different race my basic
feeling is i'm actually pretty good at
just ignoring these details it's not
that i don't see them but i don't care
that's true and
not caring is now a problem because
there's a question about do you really
care are you lying to yourself right
right and we used to be able to um
to overcome such hurdles with honesty
and with integrity and with it with an
assumption that the person on the other
side wasn't trying to be an [ __ ]
right and there are some people who are
trying to be [ __ ] sometimes and a
few who are trying to be [ __ ] all
the time but in general they're not i'm
reminded
i'm not even sure i've i've told this
but i'm reminded of it
experience that i had um we knew each
other already but um we were still in
high school
and um
i was in a photo shoot at the beach and
i was
made up and which is not my usual thing
at all
and so it was just like the cameraman
and maybe a lights person and me and
la beach in the in the late 80s and this
homeless person there were a lot of
homeless people in santa monica then but
not not nearly as many as now and you
know they were all more of a type than
the very varied homeless people we see
now and i hadn't really ever interacted
with any
and this guy comes up and he's you know
probably twice my age but not old you
know he's probably late thirties um and
um he had he was scraggly you know he
didn't certainly didn't seem dangerous
and i was there with these two guys who
were doing the the camera and light work
anyway
and um he was just watching and they
were like you know do you want him out
here
whatever um
and they said we were going to move and
he said to me
i've never met anyone like you before
and i said
totally honestly not forgetting that i
had you know a face on right i've never
met anyone like you before either
and like all three of these guys were
like
what
like no i'm i'm serious like
like where did you like how did you land
here like
and we ended up having a conversation
but really he couldn't he couldn't
fathom you know he had this sort of like
oh i'm in hollywood and this is some you
know glamour person i'm like no i'm just
like a kid who happens to you know look
like look like this whatever but i'd
like to talk to you
and he couldn't
at first he thought i was mocking him
and i wasn't of course i wasn't i mean
you know me of course i wasn't some
other people might have been yeah and we
ended up getting to talk
which struck me as oh i don't think this
guy would have approached me if i'd just
been randomly walking down the street
because people randomly walking down the
street don't want to have homeless
people come up to them yeah but because
we were sort of pinned down doing this
weird
stupid hollywood thing
um with a photo shoot he
he was allowed in
and i further opened the door and said
well let's talk and
that was fine and it was good and mostly
mostly that's not possible mostly people
don't let that be possible and it's
certainly less possible now yeah it used
to be that within a few i mean and i i
still have experiences like this but it
used to be that you know a few words
made it very clear that you were just a
stranger looking to connect in some way
yeah right and
it's amazing how how much harder that's
become
yeah
yeah really it
really is
um
so
the segway
ah the segway to the next thing was
acquiescence
um to the the norm to the the
conversation that sounds like what
everyone else is having
actually looks really dreary it's not
interesting that's the thing that's not
interesting it it it you you end up
living on your knees in a grayscape
and you had an experience this week at
the moment
multnomah county sheriff's office yeah
that right you have that correct i went
to the multnomah county sheriff's office
was not expecting
anything extraordinary and zach do you
want to put up those pictures
any of the outside ones huh there's the
inside one
here's the outside so the multnomah
county
sheriff's office multnomah county is the
county that portland is in
and the sheriff's office is
essentially completely boarded up in
fact this is a live office this is this
is their central office well as i pulled
up my sense was i must be in the wrong
place this is obviously not an active
building right right doesn't look like
it doesn't look like an active building
and you know the only thing that
suggested otherwise was that the parking
lot was full of cars so for people who
are just listening you've got a i don't
know it almost looks like it could be an
elementary school or something yeah like
sort of a
flat
not very interesting
lee architected building but not a piece
of glass visible on the outside it's all
got plywood on the windows well i think
partly
it's the plywood on the windows that
makes it look like that the entrance is
actually sort of grand and there's a big
atrium on the inside okay but it looks
like a defunct building right it looks
like a building that's been condemned
and is going to be torn down and so
anyway i parked in the parking lot there
was a sheriff
talking to another sheriff through the
window of a car and i said how do you
get into the building and they're like
oh it's just around the front
which seemed odd because there was
nothing about this building that looked
like anybody could walk through a door
in the front it looked closed yeah so i
walked through the door
in the front maybe that first excuse me
that first picture again you want to go
back to that first picture
it's completely dark in there because
the design of the building is they have
these
large banks of windows on three you've
got like clear story windows and then
also an entire bank um that we're
looking at in front of us here that's
what it does as well yeah so the the
atrium here is 20 feet tall with a huge
uh number of windows on three sides that
are supposed to be bathing it in light
during the day and you walk in and it's
completely dark because there's no
alternative plan for the light
you know and it's just a boarded up
building and
even more shocking the glass has been
broken out
and
it's just been left jagged
up in these high former window panes
right this is the nama county sheriff's
office this is the
county this is presumably from the
unrest in quotes that happened more than
a year ago in the summer of 2020. yeah i
did some looking i wanted to make sure
there wasn't some event that i didn't
know about right i mean you know
what could it be other than the unrest
but anyway what all i could find was
that april
of 2020 was when this building was
attacked no why would it have been
attacked in april 29th that doesn't make
any sense sorry
hold on okay
uh so you were there this week and um i
think not nothing was happening
rioting or protest wise in the streets
of portland until after george floyd's
death which was yeah i'm sorry that
isn't the right date let me see if i can
while we're talking come up with the
news report
but in any case the point was um
i'm not gonna be able to do it
the point was
somehow this building was damaged by
rioters who of course have attacked the
police in portland uh in the same way
that police have been attacked all over
the country
um
more vigorously
but more consistently right you know
uninterrupted months of it in the summer
into the fall of 2020 right um and
uh the
building has been left this way
in a sense it's impossible for me to
really even imagine that any active
workplace could be left in this
condition even just the psychological
impact of having had people
hostile to you
engaged in this kind of violent
destructive behavior damage your
building and then you're expected to go
in there and see the reminder that these
people and work in darkness work in
darkness right it's an inhumane
condition
and it's um and it's a kind of
acquiescence like what well it's clear
acquiescence in fact what must have
happened here is that there was a
decision not to fix this yeah right i
guess i i very much want to know that
there hasn't been that there wasn't
something recent that happened yeah um
but
you know if
if not we're talking about months maybe
even more than a year of um of a
workplace
um you know
people who are who are working
civic jobs should be able to work in a
place
that feels humane and this is this is
absurd yeah it's absurd it's inhumane
and it you know we are now seeing
uh
a conspicuous lack of law enforcement
and i have to say as much as
on the one hand i know that that ends in
disaster and i feel like hey look the
police are obligated to be enforcing the
law because a lot of us are depending on
the law being enforced rule of law is
the key concept here that uh prevents
terrible people from
uh ruining our way of life yeah i also
do have some sympathy where the police
watched the country turn on them and
even though most people didn't believe
it
the fact is because people were
intimidated and didn't speak up
uh it effectively
you know the the police were left with
this vile stigma being leveled at them
all cops are bastards right all over
portland there were
suggestions that cops were deserving of
being killed
there were there was an incident we
talked about on darkhorse
at the time
where a severed pig's head was lit on
fire in front of the courthouse
and anyway to find that the damage
to
a
sheriff's building has just simply been
left there as if
the decision-making entity presumably
the sheriff didn't decide to leave the
building this way although i'd be
curious what the decision-making process
was but that somebody has decided
that the protesters had a good enough
point
that uh that they should be left that
their statement of destruction should be
left
as it was and unrepaired is mind-blowing
to me
yeah
it is
uh
you the next thing you want to talk
about was this um
show an excerpt from the
the video
done by the mats
yeah um
so
many people will have seen this now matt
taibi
put out a piece that he teamed up with
and i apologize to the second matt in
this case whose name i'm going to i at
one point knew but i think it's
uh matt orfalia do i have it right i
would have said orphalia but um either
way we got we got spelling here has a
certain ring to it maybe it's not our
philia and if it's not matt orfelia matt
maybe you should consider that
pronunciation but uh
said the two people on set who's whose
people's names never get right never
corrected never said correctly but
anyway zach do you want to show just a
couple of 30 seconds of an excerpt from
the video uh that matt tybee includes
the videos done by matt the teenager
drove from his home in illinois
approximately one mile to wisconsin
across state lines driving across state
borders he's driving across state lines
across the state line across state lines
across state lines across state lines if
you look at the rent house case he
crossed state lines drives up to two
events across state lines came across
state lines kyle rittenhouse who
traveled across state lines from out of
state out of his own state came across
state borders whenever you have a
situation where a 17 year old is
crossing state
so the um
i had a lot of reactions when you showed
me this last night um and one of them
was
crossing straight line
crossing state lines is like horse
dewormer
yeah so there's obviously
a narrative however this happened
putting entirely aside
what you think about
either
either written house or ivermectin yep
right um but the the use of a thing a
phrase
that can instill fear or mockery in the
case of across state lines oh
people i hear crosstalk lines it's
usually with you abducted children
that's not good or horsty warmer oh
these idiots
right
yeah
i think the point is it takes a
i wish there weren't two mats in the
story because i would just call him matt
but
matt orfalia or philia matt orfelia's
compilation here just making it worse
i'm sorry um
demonstrates that there was an unnatural
uh an unnatural
um
what's the term
uh
consensus yeah that's not a consensus
it's an it's an unnatural convergence on
a particular way of describing these
events that leave a very particular
impression
well but convergence
actually takes some of the onus off like
almost certainly there were talking
points delivered well of course i i
think this is likely how they ended up
in all of these mouths i don't know it
could be a matter of contagion where
there is a style of thought that now has
whatever the particular political uh
apparatus whatever it thinks gets
dispensed and spreads as people repeat
each other's
phraseology or it could be that there's
something more nefarious and directed
but the basic point is look
you had an event it was actually a
complex event right you had a kid who
obviously did something stupid in a
country where
we have a particular relationship with
firearms but the point is the portrayal
of the story of
rittenhouse having traveled across state
lines traveled across state lines leaves
the impression that he made a long trip
right which suggests something about
what he was up to it's actually
inconsistent with what actually happened
here whatever you think of it
um and so the point is to have
screen after screen barking the same
thing well what was the average person's
experience of this
the average person's experience of this
is it didn't matter what screens they
encountered the screen would say this
phrase but until you knew that every
other screen was saying it and it was
unnatural
then you wouldn't necessarily think you
had a misimpression of the story
and so
your point about horse dewormer
standing where we were standing suddenly
every speaker on earth erupted in horse
dewormer at the same moment every screen
portrayed horses dewormer pace the the
story it
unfolded in the most nearly sudden
it was like
the week of horse dewormer right and
suddenly this was on everybody's mind it
was you know
uh it was about feed stores it was that
damn
fda picture of the vet stroking the
horse's nose or whatever right it was it
was the uh the hospital in oklahoma
oh the hospital
right people car crashes gunshots
gunshot victims who during the summer
gunshot victims were standing in parkas
outside the hospital unable to get in
because of all of the overdoses and
right and so the point was that was a
very unnatural story too that didn't
stand up at all to scrutiny it also just
again revealed what the you know the
the playmakers in the media are
among the class that would call
themselves the coastal elites and like
actually really view the so-called
flyover states with such with such
disdain and you know we've seen this
professors with students as well with
such disdain
that it didn't even occur to them that
in the summer in oklahoma they might not
be wearing parkas like they have that
little model of what is going on well i
don't even think that's it i think the
way this works
it triggers a verificationist circuit
right and the point is
but basic fact check
but this is my point if you are in an
actual fact if you are in a very if you
are in a verificationist mindset right
then your brain
doesn't see
the
parka in august
right because it doesn't fit it's
looking only for confirmatory evidence
and so the point is if you were looking
for evidence that all of those people
who keep showing up with uh this
inconvenient counter narrative are
actually just dummies right then the
point is it doesn't really matter that
the stuff that
glues the story together doesn't add up
what you're looking for just like with
the crossing state lines right exactly
oh it was a mile away a lot of his
family lived there and he worked there
and and the gun was the gun was there
already he didn't take a gun and drive
across state lines right he drove across
town and i mean the other thing is
okay you were at the multnomah county
sheriff's office this week um happens we
live in multnomah county but there's two
other counties right here parts of
portland are in it you know do you did
you drive across county lines this week
brett i bet you did you know like yo
since when are is this line the one that
matters you know did you cross the
street
right
which boundaries are we going to get
concerned about in order to instill fear
in people and to continue to continue to
drum up a freaking race war so when
actually what we should all agree on is
that that is not what we want why do
some people appear to want
the division so so
this is this is the point you've got
a story that doesn't hang together but
if you're only paying attention to it
you know out of the corner of your
eye yeah you
it's sort of like okay i get it
right wing kid drove a long way with a
high-powered weapon those people looking
for trouble right
so you just sort of put it together that
way but what i don't understand and the
thing that drives me crazy
is at the point you discover that there
is a
well-resourced
campaign to convince you of something
why do you not become immediately
skeptical of everything said by those
same people
right at the point you discover
that you know oh yeah there was this
week where i started to think it was
clever to invoke horse dewormer to
dismiss a whole bunch of people the idea
that actually that wasn't really my idea
right that was
cnn's idea and nbc's idea and it was the
washington post and it was you know all
of these outlets simultaneously making
this clever you know and in fact the the
great example of this is the dean scream
right um uh from howard dean's uh
renegade presidential campaign 96 maybe
when you know i think when clinton was
running the second time yeah i think uh
eric has talked about this as well but
the point was there was one evening dean
came out of nowhere
howard dean whose slogan or catch phrase
was he was from the democratic wing of
the democratic party right which was
hilarious because the democratic party
wasn't yet as bad as it is now but the
point is it was being taken over by this
other thing and the idea that there were
still people within the democratic party
who
were fundamentally about democracy this
point being bill was not from the
democratic wing of the democratic party
right and so the thing that happened was
uh
he
i think he had lost a primary and he was
trying to he was trying to he was saying
look this isn't over we're gonna go to
hmm and then we're gonna go to hmm and
he had a horse voice from campaigning or
something and he yeah his voice broke as
he was
doing something and if you'd been
standing there you would have thought
i didn't actually see an event but
it got recorded i didn't actually see an
event right can we create an event where
an event didn't even happen right so we
can the point is they
broadcast this thing incessantly as if
it was like some embarrassing gaffe i
mean there was literally nothing to it
yeah and then the late night comedians
were like relentless joking about howard
dean and it was like that's the end of
his presidential campaign the dame
scream the dean's scream so anyway at
the point you discover that you've been
dean screamed
right at the point you discover that
that joke that you thought was clever
was actually not your idea that you were
doing the bidding of something that
wanted everyone to think this was a
clever joke during a particular week in
august or whenever it was
um
you should say hey
okay i don't know what's going on here
it's interesting that there appears to
be a campaign to convince me
that um
ivermectin doesn't work and it's only
for dummies right and horses
it's you're not carnival
no absolutely not
but the point is at the point you
discover there's a campaign to convince
me of something
then you ought to look i mean it's like
if somebody lied to you right if
somebody lied to you on a bunch of
fronts right if somebody sold you you
know i don't know a piece of property a
car something and they told you like a
bunch of things that turned out not to
be true
and then you ran into them again and
they started telling you more things you
would be naturally skeptical you should
be
um so anyway that's how skepticism is
supposed to work that is how skepticism
is supposed to work it is interesting
though that people's skepticism is not
triggered by um the discovery that they
themselves have been broadcasting a
story that was created for them that
does not match the facts that they now
know and the interesting thing about
this trial is that it revealed these
facts yes even if many people refuse to
accept it and they
they speak as if the verdict is clear a
clear evidence of white supremacy which
of course makes no sense no it doesn't
um but
um this is actually this actually does
work as a segment we just read a lot of
different
things we want to talk about this week
and i think it is actually kind of all
all of a theme
the atlantic
monthly the uh
got one of the longest running monthly
magazines um sort of culture culture and
art magazines
um in the u.s since since the 1800s i
think um
is has gone full gossip on vaccines
so let me see i have
um
somewhere if i can pull it up if my
thing will work here
here we go
zachary you can show my screen now this
is um just this is a pdf of the atlantic
article
um
it's called this is the atlantic daily
so this is just one of you know
quickly produced so this is not an
extensively researched long time in the
works piece by any means but the
atlantic daily not everyone needs to
rush for a booster so i'm on i'm on the
atlantic's email list and i get their
daily emails and i saw this on the email
and went and just downloaded the pdf
the united states is reportedly gearing
up to authorize covet 19 boosters for
all adults should you snap one up or
wait here's what to consider
now the author of this carolyn mims nice
if the booster rollout is a tv show as
my colleague rachel guttmann once joked
this evening bought it brought a juicy
if not entirely unexpected plot twist
according to the new york times the fda
and cdc are moving to make pfizer
boosters available to all adults not
just those at higher risk
so should you rush out for your extra
dose to help you figure out what's right
in your situation i spoke with three
reporters who have been covering the
vaccine roll out sarah zhang catherine
jay wu and rachel gutmann previously
mentioned to weigh the pros and cons of
running out immediately versus sitting
tight
i'm going to share a few of these things
but that right there that should be
enough right so some
and i did not i did not go and research
any of these four women they are
apparently
um journalists who have been covering
this story
that actually tells us nothing about
whether or not they are they know
anything they have done any assessment
of their own whether or not they are
able to um
what are you doing trying to find that
date okay
it's very hard for me to talk with
other things going on right here okay so
we have these four people um who are
maybe journalists
claim to be journalists but we have no
idea whether or not they've been right
about stuff and you know i could have
done that but
um
here we have some of the things they say
this is this is supposed to be what you
the um
you know educated reader of the atlantic
is going to look to to decide whether or
not to get your booster
that say so of
four people who have apparently know
no particular background here why hurry
this is why hurry versus why wait on
your booster why hurry the shot will
well give you a boost
you're likely already while protected
from severe disease hospitalization and
death thanks to your first course rachel
pointed out but the early science
suggests that extra doses help your body
produce additional antibodies perhaps
lowering your risk of infection
that's a lot of hearsay and a lot of
this this this friend of mine says
therefore let's do it
why harry you're around higher risk
people
parents who are trying to protect
unvaccinated kids for example might
consider using a booster as an
additional precaution sarah told me
so two things happening in that one
sarah told me so the person writing this
article is taking no responsibility but
she's only deferring responsibility to
someone else with
lack of of actual ability to assess the
evidence
you're around higher risk people parents
who are trying to protect unvaccinated
kids for example
those two sentences put next to each
other as they are makes it sound
like
unvaccinated children are higher risk
people yep unvaccinated children are not
higher risk people
unvaccinated children are very very low
risk people healthy children don't die
from this disease
healthy children
are at
some risk from the vaccines and it
very much
less risk almost certainly from the
disease not only low risk from the
disease but there is a discussion that
we are not having
which is
the
the vaccines
which is not the right term for them but
nonetheless the vaccines
to the extent that they provide
short-term protection
may actually
stave off disease long enough that it is
a danger so for children yes yeah it is
not entirely unlike the situation that
caused um
parents of our parents generation to put
kids of our generation in contact with
each other when they had chickenpox
which was that it wasn't a serious
threat to our health as children and it
could be a serious threat to our health
later and so there was an argument for
it it was effectively
a crude natural vaccination process
and the idea that
i mean i guess the problem is that
they've just simply rolled the logic in
so that you don't check it the idea that
children need to be protected from this
and therefore parents might do so by
right
is
uh upside down yep um
so anyway yes it's uh it's it's just
it's like um
uh
it's conversational
argumentation that doesn't subscribe to
any of the uh the normal rules exactly
and because it is is produced here as if
it's conversation it is i think also
being held to a lower standard even by
most readers so
next one you
why hurry you plan to gather over the
holidays on average antibodies peak
three weeks post booster rachel
explained
how
that's amazing three weeks post booster
and then it starts to decline so that's
something right there that they're even
admitting that but earlier the very
first one was um
early science suggests that extra doses
help your body produce additional
antibodies perhaps lowering your risk of
infection
so you just aiming for like the one
moment when you think you're going to be
at highest risk and you give three weeks
post booster and then like that's your
magic moment and after that you're
you're less safe like none of this is
tracking none of this is is a coherent
message
why wait why wouldn't you go get your
booster right now even though
you're allowed to
we don't know how to optimize vaccine
timing yet boosters haven't been
available that long so the science on
timing is preliminary
you don't say
extra doses mean extra chances of side
effects
getting a booster could increase your
risk of rare side effects katie
explained quote there's a reason we
don't boost unnecessarily end quote but
that she added is not a reason to not
get jabbed if you do need it and how do
you decide if you do need it i wonder
that's left for us to decide
finally keep the bigger picture in mind
boosters aren't a silver bullet katie
reminded me and though this won't be
solved by you
foregoing an extra shot there are lots
of people in the world who haven't even
gotten their first dose yet that's worth
remembering
what
yeah it's a total non-sequitur
whether or not you are going to for your
own health and because you have or have
not seen various things about what these
boosters are what the vaccines that you
got in the first place were
has absolutely nothing to do with
whether or not there are people who you
think should have had access to the
vaccines and don't yet literally nothing
yeah
zero there is zero relationship between
those two things this is this is typical
just
garbage
pseudo-causal
liber liberal seeming argumentation that
actually makes no sense it's um
it's effectively like uh the clean plate
club logic like this is exactly what it
is yeah that's that's i mean that's
exact that's exactly what it's alluding
to yeah right
you have to eat your dinner because
there are children in fill in the blank
china you know starving i don't know
what people say anymore but um that no
actually that's that's that's a
non-sequitur yeah it's a it's a
non-sequitur i mean the whole thing is a
non-sequitur and so but keep the bigger
picture in mind brett well but
you know there's something about the
chatty pseudological
argumentation
right and in some sense basically what
this is modeling is
if you're going to make this argument
you know what will come back at you and
what might you say right and it's
sort of like it it's just well katie
said right
but you know you can imagine just
substituting yourself as if you're being
clever saying these things but the
question is you're not really being
clever yeah did you hear that the
booster's gonna be available oh my god i
did hear that and i heard that if i'd
take one now that that might mean that
someone else can't have it so maybe i
should wait these
it's it's nonsense it's not the way that
we should be making these decisions and
unfortunately it is the way that a bunch
of people are making decisions and this
is making that more likely yes and in
hint like increasing the odds that that
chirpy gossipy
like coffee clutch level of conversation
is the basis for decisions about your
health no no it's not no it shouldn't be
yes it's going to be you know in fact it
weirdly um harkens back to what we were
talking about earlier in the podcast
which is there are sort of two visions
of
uh
what how you will be viewed based on
your position right yeah and if you're
like yeah i'm trying to i'm trying to
get the timing of my my booster
down
right the point is well that assumes
that you're going to get one it assumes
that you should get one
and the alternative of like wait a
minute what about the adverse event
signal and do we know what that means
yet and
right that thing well you're going to be
shouted down and mocked and treated as
you know you're going to be treated as
the cause of the pandemic if you know
you're vaccine skeptical here
um and so the point is you're being
offered a choice do you want to go back
to being chatty about this kind of stuff
or do you want to be the villain right
and can't we just get back to normal
already i feel like it's you guys who
are keeping us from getting back to
normal yeah right yeah exactly and that
is not what the evidence suggests at all
not at all
not at all okay um let's finish up with
something
and now for something completely
different all right
although i alluded to it earlier
um i was
taking a walk this morning before our
live stream
and it you know we have we've traveled
so little
in almost two years now and both of us
love to travel feel that it's important
feel that um you know it would
we would have been able to show our boys
so much more of the world by now because
this was exactly the age at which we
could have been exploring places with
them and
it just hasn't been possible and it's
it's a huge loss
uh
one thing is we have been able to see um
every moment of the change of the place
we're in
we are able to just you know watch not
just seasonal changes at the level of
months um but you know which the the
order in which the leaves fall from
which trees
and um you know the way that the rain
if it comes just as they're about to
fall as opposed to after they've fallen
changes the patterns in which they are
left on the ground and you know all
sorts of things
um but it prompted me and i already
mentioned how how happy everyone seemed
out there today how willing to share
their joy everyone seemed to be out
there today and how wonderful that was
i was thinking of a student i had many
years ago obviously i haven't had a
student in a few years um
i actually don't remember much about him
i don't think that he was your student
either
um
but he was looking for a winter quarter
project
he was he wanted to come into my program
in the spring we were on a quarter
system so winter quarter would have been
january through middle of march really
you know the darkest wettest
dreariest time in the pacific northwest
and he didn't see anything in the
catalog to entice him and he was looking
for maybe an independent contract which
is like you know you i do research but
i'm not actually taking a set curriculum
um and i recommended to him as i did to
all students who were
not already dedicated to some particular
curricular or other plan uh in the
winter and who were who were free at
some level he said you know go south
travel you know either find a research
project to be an assistant on or go you
know go waffing
like
volunteering at organic farms which a
lot of our students did because they
were sort of those you know crunchy
liberal types and good honest work and
they got to interact with people from
different
different places and and have their
hands in the dirt and all this um
or
you know often what i would recommend
was because a lot of our students really
didn't have very much money
um was
given how much you want to learn
in school
take the quarter off do not pay
evergreen tuition and take the quarter
off and travel like go go somewhere and
just travel and like actually be with
other people who don't remind you of
anyone you know and learn the language
well enough to interact with them
and
um and you will be transformed in ways i
can't even begin to tell you
and
um
often when people resisted that from me
oh no i know i just need to i just need
to finish college you know can i get
college credit for that i'm like i will
i will not sign off and giving you
college credit for travel travel is
perhaps the best education you can get
but i'm not going to hand over college
credits for that even though you know
i'm supposed to do that as an employee
of the state etc like i won't i won't do
it
um i say oh yeah i'm scared oh and lots
of reasons that people didn't want to go
and travel independently or even you
know woof or do one of these other
things
but his and i wish i remembered his name
i feel like it was matt actually but i
think that's probably just because we've
been talking about mats um his
explanation for why he didn't want to
leave um the area around olympia for the
winter
was one i hadn't heard before and i
really respected it and it was
he wasn't from he was from the midwest
if i remember correctly uh and he had
moved to uh olympia a year or so before
starting school so that he could
establish residency so that he had a
tuition that was would put him in less
in debt
and
he had been there for a full year and
was now beginning his his second year
and could see already how much things
were even different from that first year
you live in a place for one year and you
feel like that's what it's like here
right and then you live in a place for a
second year and you realize oh maybe
that was an unusual year you know there
are going to be commonalities but it's
it's hard to know what to make after one
year
and he said i want to stay in one place
like actually really fully one place for
the full year and not you know go
backpacking in this and that and the
other like i did the first year before i
was in school because i want to see at
the day-to-day level
and this wouldn't have been the language
he would have used but by controlling
for place
what is it that changes over time about
this environment that i'm in because
that's the way to learn about a place
more than
by dipping in here and there and by
thinking oh well you know spring is like
this well what about this spring what
about the what about last night was dry
and today is wet and how does that
affect um the animals that i see and how
it feels when i walk out the door
dressed a certain way
and i thought
as much as
you already mentioned this you know i
want to be traveling i want to be able
to go places i haven't seen before and i
want us to be able to take our children
places they haven't seen before
but actually really getting to know a
place
intimately
and paying attention to all of the
changes not just the broad seasonal and
and climate level changes but the
weather changes and the you know the
migrations big and small is uh is
another way into understanding the world
that you're in
yeah and in fact
a hybrid model where you travel and then
you stay put somewhere is actually in
many ways the best way to discover
something important it's very easy to
travel lightly through
an area and you know you get a glimpse
of a lot of stuff
right but coming to know you know a
foreign city is a really fascinating
thing um and uh you know even it's great
if you have you know even a week in a
place can be a lot especially if you
make use of it um but sometimes if you
can move someplace for a couple months
you can really get an understanding of
what another
an alternative location on earth is
is like yeah it's an experience i think
most people just don't
get to have you know it's too tough to
arrange it especially you know once once
you do have a job that keeps you in
place although increasingly jobs don't
necessarily need to or a family and you
know in schools and such um it's harder
to do and so i you know i do encourage
those
um who are without those kinds of
commitments
i was going to say once it's possible
again although you know it may be
possible for some people now
uh it's not it's not clear what all the
restrictions are in all of the places
you know there are places certainly now
that i wouldn't go that i would have
thought i would have gone
yeah 10 years ago
but
but
both being absolutely where you are and
then also
choosing to go places that are far from
what you think
you need in order to be comfortable and
you know not going to the disney fied
versions of uh foreign places but
actually going to the real things
just provides
benefits that are unquantifiable yep
absolutely
is there anything else to talk about i
think we may have gotten there all right
i mean there is lots of stuff to talk
about but um
it's thanksgiving next week we'll be
we'll be back uh two days after
thanksgiving but um
this that was sort of a
a way to talk about being grateful for
where where we are and uh and looking
forward to even more amazing things in
the future
so we're going to take a 50-minute break
um we'll be back with a live q a you can
ask your questions at
darkhorsesubmissions.com
email logistical questions that you may
have to darkhorsemoderator gmail.com
right now at my patreon you can ask
questions for our live private q a
we've got that um welcome to complex
systems
uh merchandise up now at our store which
is um
not on the screen but here it's i don't
see it on the screen
um
store.darkhorsepodcast.org there it is
um so for those listening
store.darkhorsepodcast.org
and um we met we didn't say anything
about um about a hunter-gatherer's guide
to the 21st century which continues to
sell well and we continue to hear from
people who are being
affected positively by it and we really
we appreciate that and
we love that it is continuing to spread
and
we hope we hope that that continues into
the distant future and encourage you to
get a copy if you haven't yet
all right all right be good to the ones
you love eat good food
and get outside be well everyone
[Music]
you